欢迎收看赵华
我是赵华
我是艾伦
没想到我们也有今天
亏为三个月
台股又创历史新高了
恭喜
可是每一次创新高
大家就会担心
是不是又咕噜咕噜咕噜
要滚下来
应该不会啦
不是嘛
我们你看6月在担心
7月在担心
8月又要担心
现在创历史新高了
因为上一次创历史新高
也是收一个黑K
那今天更猛了
今天本来涨800多点
结果最后只涨80几点
所以今天拉了个800点的上影线
上影线800点
好家在
我觉得是量缩
量缩还可以接收
然后又要放假
所以大家今天可能钱卖卖
礼拜四放假钱才拿到钱
提加二
所以我觉得还可以接受
下个礼拜再来看
因为台股可能有台股
自己中秋廉价的状况
可是如果以昨天晚上
美股来说的话
是个个有表现猛将一大堆
是
好 所以我们就来解读一下
如果今天只是一个
接钱卖押的话
那接下来是不是好戏
在后头呢
今天48601
好 然后但是呢
我们先把节过了
因为看来今天
确实有一些节线调节
但是涨力强
尤其是像CPU有好消息
半导体论坛
这一半也有好消息
还有传习会等等的
都有一些支撑的力道
所以我觉得目前来说
息也升完了嘛
最痛的那一刀也砍完了
对嘛 砍完了
然后油价也跌了嘛
对 油价跌了
所以我觉得就目前来说
先不管技术面会不会跌啦
至少我觉得事件性来讲
应该短线上是比较少利空的
所以我們就來看一下
不只利空少
也有一些利多的支持
沒錯META推出了
它最新的AI代理叫做MUF
MUF
沒錯
然後自己股價就漲了11%
為什麼
因為它在美國那邊的APP
免費下載是綁手
就是它好像推出快兩禮拜
然後就熔燈綁手
對 下載超過250萬次
所以這件事情也讓大家覺得
AI其實是還是需求很大的
而且它是什麼代理人對 Asian AI 對就幫你可以下訂單才夠對 就大概是兩三個月前我們有來講過的就是之後你一支手機
你看到誰的演唱會了
他會幫你追蹤 幫我搶票
你不用跟他講
你就給你設定好 先幫你追蹤
時間到他就自己買了
所以就突然發現信用卡就跳通知
被扣款了 這樣好嗎
其實我覺得蠻方便
只是你會學莫名其妙
難怪亞馬遜其實不讓這個代理人AI
去他的網站買東西
是這樣子是不是
他說不知道後面是誰
有可能
如果這被入侵的話應該蠻嚴重
好 那不管怎麼樣
我們發現這件事情又帶動了AI的一個反攤
包含像是Meta
然後像Arm也自己長起來了
Intel有12%
AMD也市值第一次達到了1兆美元
創歷史新高的股價
是的 所以整體來講
昨天的美股尤其是半導體這一塊
它是全面紅
是
没有错
这也是带中间台湾股市
为什么可以开高的原因
开高会开高
盆中走低是走低
那纳斯达克也创下6月2号
也来新高
所以目前来说
我觉得科技股
最近又重燃了一波火势起来
是
幸好有美国科技股也跟上来
要不然我们自己在那里吹风
挺冷的
是的
这一次终于不是我们去
给他们带下来
不是说向下去找他们
是他们上来找我们了
没错没错
那再来另外一个
还有这个光通讯的大展
有开幕
在欧洲
是的
跟Lumantum
有高通有康宁
秀了D2D的互联
那瞄准的就是AI横向
扩展的架构
所以这些东西呢
就基本上
大家就稍微自己看一下
那图也结在这边
因为它这边东西
都是比较技术面上
技术产业的东西
就是他们自己
秀一些肌肉出来
那整体来讲
其实对于目前
整个CPU的族群性
我觉得应该都还是一些
持续性的利多
只不过最近的CPU的
走势有一點分析
然後老的CPU稍微
沒有這麼有活力
年輕一點的CPU比較有活力
我們等下下一段會講
所以這個是近期又有一個
相關的CPU的利多
對 好
其實主要往上
美股的CPU也是有反應的
是的 所以我覺得
CPU來講應該都還是
可以持續好好去關注的
再來看到另外一個
就是剛剛提到了國外的
我們講一下我們國內的
台積電要拼先進封裝
它也兼顧到國外
因為北美的OIP論壇
也要展開就在這裡辦所以這也辦應該台積電和相關技術的東西會很多才對所以應該還是持续会有一些看有没有大家解读利多的讯息可是今天台积电收最低没办法
今日最低
是的
可是我们的这个VCC
有说了我们股价要赶快
追上联发科
请问是要上去追到发哥5000
还是发哥要下来找台积电
应该要上去吧
如果他要5000
那就是台积电要翻倍
就是台积电当然希望往上追
对啊 所以台积电如果要翻倍
那我们台股至少
指数也要涨个80%吧
我们先看3000好不好
翻倍真的是
对 所以目前来说
它有纠团设先进封装的中心
那会在高雄
这个白浦的
白浦产业园区
对 然后会号召本土的设备
跟材料的业者去做进驻
基本上还是持续
一条龙的供应链
所以我觉得这一些未来
应该都还是从里面找商机
就是不只是台积电
台积电跟他的好朋友们
应该都可以好好注意一下
好
这个是持续上
经这几天的一些新闻
给大家观察一下
你会发现AI相关的都反映
就是大家都往正向表态
所以我觉得也是真的很神奇
你看上礼拜
上上礼拜我们还在讲
那个要暂缓发展
而且很闷
就成交量很萎缩
又担心AI
又担心升息
然后今天油价跌很重嘛
油价那个什么
西德州剩95块
原本100多
然后那个布兰特也是
跌到100元附近
所以整个科技股就飙起来了
瞬间好像利空通通不见
对 就一周的时间
台湾股市我们可以看到
今天是48601
盘中有突破了
这个6月的历史新高
但是收盘价其实是没有突破的
那就等于是挑战失败
这样说挑战失败
挑战失败
对 那挑战失败过程中还怎么样
还拉了一个800一点左右的上影线
所以这个短线上
应该就会是一个明确要整理的讯号
那不过这个整理讯号我们有说嘛
高档如果再配报大量
那可能就是涨完了的讯号
上次就有一点这个味道
是的
那可是呢
这一次其实是没有报大量的
这一次还算合理的量
对 所以我觉得还可以接受
但是单纯就这一根来讲
我个人觉得短期应该也是要出现整理的讯号
不过这个整理呢
一方面今天是礼拜二嘛
那今天卖股票礼拜四领得到钱
对 礼拜四可以拿回钱
对 可是你明天卖跟后天卖
都基本上是节后才能领到钱报股过节 报钱过节是的 所以大家可能会在今天会有做了一些节前的T加2的卖压调整那一方面就是有些交易者
喜欢是创新高开始买股票
对 所以有一些获利卖压也好
或者说有一些节前的调整也好
那造就了今天有一个上影线
我觉得是还可以接受的
那成交量 重点是成交量
没有爆得很夸张
还是在一兆左右
那我觉得这个状态之下
就还算OK
那OK过程中我们基本上
上引線嘛 所以還是要注意整理
那有幾個位置大家可以稍微觀察一下
首先是這個前高
是
這個前高是47600
其實就大概300點左右
因為今天47800嘛
所以大概差200到300點
那這個位置是原本的壓力區
所以突破轉支撐
那再來就是均線
接下來要上彎了
上彎的過程會形成一些支撐
是
就是有一些助長的效果
那只要碰到了一些支撐的
支撐區或者說關鍵的一些上彎均線
有出現了止跌的訊號
那我觉得合理都有机会
再重新挑战这个高点
那如果再做突破
那这个行情就是持续墊高了
所以目前来说我觉得短线确实
可能明后天成交量
应该会稍微萎缩一点
因为要放假了
那刚好来一个价跌量缩
然后开始酝酿可能放假后的新行情
所以下礼拜只要出现一些
更好的讯号出现
其实我觉得应该都是站在买方
对那目前来说
只会看短线要休息
但长线是多头
我觉得应该没有问题
再来另外是贵买
贵买今天也很可惜啊
都上影线
但是收盤價確實佔上了414
所以我會認為它是一個
箱形的突破
這應該都會是對長線來講是好事
當然都上影線
所以上影線我覺得
短線要休息應該都沒問題
應該都合理的
對啦 機率比較高
整理的過程只要不要有一個
什麼突然明天補大量
1.5兆下來
那這個就不行了
可是應該不太會
所以我覺得就是
這兩天沉澱一下
因為要放假
可能我覺得交易的活絡度
也會降低
那等放完架之後
再來看一下亮燈跟形態上
有沒有更進一步向上去做發展
反而是今天一開盤
那個800點有把我嚇一跳
大家好猛喔
對啊 很可惜
尾盤其實賣壓真的蠻重的
另外一塊就台積電
台大電說錯了
台大電在昨天來一個紅K
這紅K很重要 為什麼
這個是6月
一次 兩次 三次
到了這一次第五次
終於站上季線
所以我覺得是一個
非常重要的一個訊號
就是這六十天買的人
終於賺錢了
對 那賺錢了呢
這裡做突破
趁現在要挑戰這個地方
這個地方是一個
所以這裡要做突破
這WD就確立了
那我覺得已經打兩隻腳了
剩下是高點要去做突破
因為它都低檔有量耶
低檔有人想要買它
果然是好公司
是的 所以我覺得它這邊開始有在
展現台達電應該要有的樣子
因為開始Q4也要出貨了
對 所以我覺得
之前的一些良率問題
或者說出貨低延的問題
應該開始慢慢消化掉了
再來應該是光寶科
光寶科這一波走勢
比台達電來的強很多
先創新高的是它
是 那不过在后面这一阵子
也是一路整理到270块
开始足底
那今天很可惜
来到300又开高走低
但我觉得这边已经出现了一个
开始足底的讯号
所以在这个位置上
我觉得光宝科
上升趋势线跌破了
那开始走整理
但周围里来到这个位置
应该也要在这边做足底
所以我觉得有一个赚赔比的
或者说非常好抓停顺的位置出现了
就是270跌破
因为跌破这边就是导N型
可是如果这边没跌破
那后面
我觉得宝宝科的产业的状态
应该不会输台亚电
对 所以我觉得后续
应该是值得期待
这个是两个电源的全资股
顺便跟大家稍微分享一下
技术面上的状态
好 当然台积电今天
收的比较低是有点可惜
但是也把空间等于
让出来给大家
后续还是很值得期待
也可能是有这个
提款效应的关系
所以广告回来
我们会继续聊下去
有这么多的好消息
有一个事情很特别
Intel为什么大涨
有人說Intel是因為跟友達結盟做CPU
我第一次聽到有台灣的廠商跟美股
就是合作是長在美股身上
當然友達今天也很強
所以延伸這個話題我們來看一下
到底整體的CPU狀況如何呢
OK 來吧
這個很奇妙的事情
當然我不覺得單純是因為
友達和Intel要合作
Intel大漲
但是因為確實友達也很強
Intel也很強
是的
這Intel昨天12%的漲
對啊
我們是漲停板
沒錯
所以我覺得
可是我覺得應該也沒有
因為這位半導體也很強
對啦
所以我說不應該只是因為這樣
可能剛好有這個新聞出現
那有傳出來
Intel 攜手友達要強攻CPU
先進封裝這一塊
所以又有一個利多給了友達
那友達這兩天的股價都是漲停板的那我們今天來講的剛剛有提到最近的老CPU除了可能全新之外那普遍的比如说什么波罗威是联雅
或者是说这种上全
光盛
其实股价
当然前面有反弹
但是现阶段比较
温吞一点点
可是呢有一些新的CPU
开始在陆区强势起来
就是扩散出来
甚至说它的股价比较便宜
几十块
没错
什么光顶
电源
真的很猛
对
然后还有什么
聯誼光嘛
所以反而是這一波的新的CPU
反而股價比較強一點
擴散效應又來了
對 所以大家反而還是會喜歡
新的題材
因為可能友達也轉型
台表科轉型
穩帽是沒有轉型
但穩帽也就還是
近期的表現還可以
林光通也是有說要做FAEU
所以股價也是底部出現了一個
兩根左右的漲停板
那我們今天來跟大家講的
就是前面這四位
稍微來看一下
目前的一些題材
跟技術面上的走勢
那友達其實他本來就跟群創是做一樣面板
那其實他們本業也有利多
因為中國這邊也傳要漲價
然後他們的價動力降低
所以不只是供給變少
然後單價也變高
所以以本業來講應該還不錯
再來另外一個就是群創
他有FOP、OP、CPO
友達就比較偏向CPO一點點
友達又傳可能跟台積電合作
是啊 中科廠可能會賣給台積電
對 3.5跟7.5
对 然后再来是
群创是强上半年
然后友达反而题材
在下半年之后发酵
一样的题材
一模一样
对 但是是先后的顺序
现在是强在友达上
对 所以大家如果你去看群创
群创其实是被季线压着
然后股价是稍微比较温吞一点点
对 可是友达就因为有一些利多
然后又卖场又一些借钱
有借很多钱
然后跟英特尔又合作
所以股价最近的表现
这两天的成交的
应该都是台股最大
那它今天创下了
歷史的最大量
你会关注这个事情吗
有涨停我就不关注
对
我今天幸好它有锁住
有有有打开过
中间一直开开关关
洗了一百多万张的成交量
没错
这太吓人了
所以我觉得
接下来走势
应该都还是盘中
都要注意震荡
一百多万张
对 我觉得隔日冲跟当冲
已经超多了
这个这么好冲
的量这么大
那不过呢
至少技术面上
N字形嘛
然后也突破了
今年7月的高點
所以我覺得形態上
又收漲停
應該沒有太多問題那不過短線當然嘛越來越多人知道它的這個非常活潑是 所以我覺得交易的人会变多那就要看一下筹码的变化跟形态上有没有转弱譬如说明天啊
这成交量这么粗
然后呢开高走低黑K
这么粗是要200万
太可怕了吧
不要说不可能啊
它最近这么吸睛
然后如果有上影线
那记得做一些调整
好 大家一定要留意哦
对 没错
所以我觉得目前来说
有达两根涨停嘛
应该N字形
大家就可以再稍微关注一下
是 应该给一个奖状
忘记了 上次有讲
那再另外一个就是台表科
哎呦 怎么会轮到他啊
台湾表面黏着科技
我们都叫他表哥啊
那表哥以前股性很不舒服
没错 其实他就是做代工嘛
对嘛 他就是我把东西给你
原物料要给你
我帮你把这些东西
焊接到板子上面嘛
对 那目前来说台表科呢
有接到Cohenium跟AOIA的订单
是 对那这些都是
毛利率比他本业来的高
另外一個呢
它也有接到美光跟常新存儲的訂單
就是要記憶體封裝
它也幫你把東西都黏上去
這些東西呢 毛利率也不低
你怎麼會發現它咧
因為表哥的範圍
本來就很廣 黏黏黏黏黏
對 因為表哥其實在前面古载之前
他那一波其實草的題材是一樣的
他有凶過一段時間
他那個時候就有接到那個AOI的
Cohenium的
然後再來就還有像類似正文
網通那一塊
也都有類似接到一樣的題材
我覺得形態上今天這個漲停
也出現了一個N字型的走勢
所以我覺得這邊
應該都還是一個不錯的狀態
那成交量也放出來了
對 所以我覺得
都可以持續觀察一下
如果有回落均線跟上
大家可以去注意一下新的買電
是 這是表哥的部分
再來一個就是瑞萱
他也是比較有趣的
對 他之前也是從那種十多塊
就忽然狂噴說有CPO
沒錯 那這一陣子呢
瑞萱他其實
之前也是做電子消費性代工
所以也沒什麼錢可以賺
對
不過這一次
傳說有跟
不是傳啦
就是新聞有寫
就是有做到波若威的shuffle box
沒錯 幫忙他做代工
後面對於他營收貢獻來講
應該會值得期待
因為他的營收其實
以本業來講是比較疲弱一點的
對 這一波修正
目前到這個地方
這邊也是一個N字形
到這個地方
到這裡為止
其實都還維持一個
上升趨勢的結構
可是短線上確實在這個地方遇到了一些這個阻力了然後今天跌破五月均線所以這邊開始在震盪的時候前滴要守好那這邊走一個整理那走整理前滴如果有守好
那上去的時候這邊要做突破
做突破這個形態就會打出來
新的多方就會繼續做延伸
所以上陣趨勢還在
這個地方短線要做一些挑戰
看能不能挑戰過去
挑戰過去就安全了
對 所以目前來說
瑞萱也遇到一些整理
那這兩天黑K都亮縮
所以我覺得也還可以接受
那就等这个均线慢慢跟上
有没有一些助长的效果
这个是瑞旋的部分
也是偏转机股
没错
这个也是转机题材股
另外一个就是稳豹
好
这个就比较正统了
对不对
这个零花音等等的
然后也逐渐从
这个传统的消费性电子
走向AI领域了
是的
这个之前
这个以三五族来讲的话
其实联雅应该是最强的
那不过这一波是全新最强
而且全新股价是超过文貌的
这个也是蛮有趣的
本来文貌是先领先的
是的 后面就发现
其实就有比较不一样一点
可能全新跟联雅在涨的是
所谓的零化音
比较纯一点点
文貌就没有到纯的零化音
目前来说它有相关的化合物半导体
微波通讯
有光源键的代工
养猪的都卖掉了
之前大概就是比较旧的题材
目前来说
整個表現上已經開始進入一個量產
所以營收應該有機會競爭
然後一成以上跟毛利率應該會維持在三成以上
其實我覺得都還算是有在成長的
再來就是技術面的部分
目前短線上聯亞是一個明確的休息的走勢
然後全新是高漲整理
不過穩帽這邊有慢慢拉出一個N字型的走勢
這裡是第一段
大家一起漲的時候
然後開始走休息
然後這個時候又是大家一起漲的時候
然後全新就自己上去了
穩帽就在這邊走整理
整理的過程呢
碰到了一樣上升趨勢的位置
這兩點連成一線
就開始有一個新的行情
那這個行情來到這個地方
它今天收盤價
其實是有站上前高的
所以N字形應該有機會
繼續向上去做延伸
但是波度就會比較緩一點
我覺得穩帽就反而是
如果你成本拉得比較開的
那我覺得抱起來還滿舒服的
就是它整理的時候
至少它整個趨勢慣性
拉得非常明顯
也就是說如果你要做一個
停利或停損
那就是月線做跌破
然後呢
或者是高檔的時候
走回落又爆了一個大量
再去做調整就好
目前的型態
我覺得都沒有太多問題
大家可以去參考一下
都是多方的結構
好 所以等于是有这种属于
有点中高价的
然后像刚刚讲的几十块的转机股
反正本益比都那么高了
那几十块的转机
应该也很有吸引力才对
没错 所以大家如果看基本面
其实有点难做CPU
没错
大家可以看一下量价
跟技术面上的形态
好 所以这边的话
喜欢CPU的朋友
其实CPU有节奏的
先反弹的可能会是
所谓的老CPU
一线CPU像联雅就领军了
可是接下來就會有擴散效應
這幾天雖然台股創歷史新高
可是不是台積電帶動的
反而很多中小型的低價股
非常的活潑
大家可以著亮的試試看
因為進場的成本跟壓力
會比較低一點點
可是他們的基本面不好參考
所以一定要看他們的技術形態
來做操作
那如果需要今天所有的圖卡資料
歡迎訂閱一下
我們趙華艾倫說的YouTube頻道
我們會把它放在首頁的天文欄
尤其是等一下的大来宾
过去是半导体产业的工程师
转入了当产业分析师
准备了超过20张的产业投影片
需要的朋友
真的要把我们订阅起来
等一下我们就来欢迎大来宾吧
欢迎回到赵华
艾伦说
我想要问艾伦
如果让你重新选择一次职业
你会选什么呢
可以选那种
譬如说郭台铭的儿子
不是职业 不是选投胎
这样不是职业
儿子这个身份
不是
我选什么
我希望可以不要被管的职业
现在也没人管你
所以就可能还是会是
以这个方向出发
对
不要管我这样子
叹逆的个性是不是
但是我们今天的大来宾很厉害
他其实有机会
或是他当过人人称县的半导体工程师
要是到现在可能分红一年都几个亿了
可是他却选择当分析师
到底哪里想不开呢
我们先来欢迎他
就是普惠头顾的我们的半导体分析师
黎智健 Vic
哈喽大家好
我是Vic
很花俏耶
大家没办法当工程师
但是很花俏没关系
因为Vic有一个座右铭
花落盛开
蝴蝶自來對 這個剛才有人講這個如果是蒼蠅的話代表這個花不是很好的花可是以前就看到這句話你們應該有聽過對不對
因為我發現就是當這個做得很好
不管在各行更業做得很好
然後身邊就會有很多資源
開始往他靠近
有沒有發現那個很成功的人
不用請客別人都請他
明明他口袋錢最多
然後再來就是如果衍生出來的話
讓我們期許自己能夠
變成一個盛開的花對不對
還在還在含包待放
然後但是呢
如果
欸 引用到股市也可以
是
是不是
這個有些好的公司啊
他其實盛開的時候
就發現資金開始湧出
然後一天成交量幾十萬張
可是在這個
很多新聞啊
消息還沒出來之前
他的基本面
還沒被大家看到的時候
欸 罰人問津
我覺得都一樣
一樣的道理
好 Vic 的意思是
因為他是一朵美麗的花
所以他愛開在哪裡
蝴蝶都會來找他
我希望未來有機會
不是蒼蠅
但是還是要問了
因為這兩個行業應該都不錯
但是半導體工程師
可能大家會更有感覺
分紅配股
股價都上千元
為什麼不繼續當工程師
要來當產業分析師
其實我覺得跟艾倫講是一樣
不想要被管
這個當到後面
當著人家都說
這個做得高不如做得穩
領得多不如領得久
所以當到這個高階主管之後
我發現這個壓力其實真的是
不成比例的變大
然後也不太想說
受制在這個體系裡面
那反而發現了另一個興趣
就投資
大家其實都有投資的興趣
每個人都想要在辦公室
廁所裡
都會有投資的興趣
但是我發現我那個興趣
是很濃厚的
我在這個出差的飛機上面
我不是在看公司的報告
我都是在看那個線圖
所以呢
你的薪水小偷
對啊 薪水小偷
出差的飛機上
那時間是我的
然後所以呢就會想說
那未來我要當一個分析師
然後就剛好有機會
就是因為認識了老王嘛
然後呢他也是在
他說你有產業的經驗
那過去的分析師其實
大部分都是財經背景
金融背景
那你是產業出來的
而且你從這個底下的
這個產品工程師
一直到行銷
一直到這個策略
那你都知道
那你原始來這邊
有一個發揮的地方
然後我就覺得還不錯
所以我就去考分析師
所以我覺得不錯
是因為你念的是理工科對不對理工科出來的話你先選擇進產業再進來當分醫師可是如果你念的是商學相關的就不一定能進去當半導體工程師了是啊其實我是不務正業
當初學者也有去面試排輯電
如果面試排輯電
現在就不會有VIC了
你就會待在那裡
我就待在那裡了
我前幾天才一個學長
才密我
他說
你是XXX老師的學生嗎
我是你學長
然後我說學長好
你在哪裡
他說他在台積電17年
是
哇
這個
我覺得如果我繼續在那邊的話
應該也是不錯的啦
那你可以把學長挖過來當產業分析師啊
學長現在人家成就很好的
是我們要現在跟他看齊
但是我覺得很厲害的一點是
因為Vic真的待過產業
所以目前你可以分辨的出來
現在大家都在漲嗎
因為AI時代
我們台灣得天獨厚
幾乎每一個領域都說跟AI有關
可是漲到這裡
你覺得誰是被低估的
當然誰可能已經Price in了
其實我覺得百花齊放
就很多產業它都在成長中
都在缺料中
技術都在進步中
那但是有些股價已經在反應中
那我覺得目前仍然是合理的
像最近的這個先進封裝
封裝相關的族群
那算是合理
另外CCL ABF
還有MLCC
因為做了一個比較大的修正
所以反而在合理的區間內
但是啊最近有一些
大家常常就是念的出口的
一些專有名詞
以前都不認識的
比如說 CPO
FOPOP
玻璃基板 TGV
那這種反而很難評估
所以你不能說
它是合理還是不合理
有的已經反應很合理
超過了
但有的還是不合理
因為它未來的這個成長
它是有這種方倍的機會
所以有些很難評估
再來呢
我覺得有些是被低估
你明明看到它
未來成長性很高
或是說甚至連八月份
講出來的成績答案
都是很好的
可是呢
就是不反應
就是不反映像是電力啊
或是像產物工程
明明在手訂單這麼多
合約負債這麼高
可是股價就是相對疲弱
但是未來還是看得見
這個可能要有信念
因為我們常常講
會不會股價不漲
就算它背後的問題
但你覺得這個產業真的沒問題
對啊
因為AI是在泡沫之前
不管泡沫還是泡沫之後
它的這個 input
always是電力
那電力進來以後才有 output
才有 token
不管在訓練的時候
還是在推論的時候都需要很多的電力
我們從很多報告可以看出來目前AI的電力荒從明年開始有非常大的缺口一直不斷產生那有哪些缺口我可以自己Q下一頁因為今天VIC準備的資料非常多
對 我們翻業的速度比翻業還快
這個大家會很擔心
因為很多雜音
包含是AI要放緩速度
或是說地方政府開始叫
這些AI Data Center賣一點蓋
或是不給你核准權
但是實際上影響並不高
我們實際上去看
它到底影響多少
數字能夠說話
譬如說
300個地方政府
實際上只有影響2.3GW
2.3到底是多還是少
我不知道對不對
可是我們看到明年
有38GW
是兩倍在成長中
而且這是核准的
可以繼續走的
所以比例上一看
大家就知道
其實影響並不大對不對
進行中的
而且很多啊
透過他們
BTM的部分
就是Behind Meter
他們自己可以自備電力
自己去產生電
所以會跟像 BE 這種公司合作
更快的可以產生出電給 Data Center 用
那這種情況下核准機率又變高了
再加上有些只是暫緩而已
可能三四個月之後
它又合可了嘛 對不對
因為這種競賽大家不能落後
那我們可以看到
積櫃的數量持續在翻倍中
而且價格啊
就是它的含金量也越來越高
那這個部分就大家不要太疑慮
未來還是持續在電力上有很大的需求
地方政府會這樣限制
也是因為他們覺得電力或基礎設施來不及
是不是
對 沒有錯
因為很多的這個 data center
其實受惠的還是 CSP 業者
對於一般居民
哇 這些電力設施在我隔壁
我才不要
我賺不到錢
這不是台灣很容易發生
美國地不是很大嗎
對啊 不然就免費
Gamini 給人家用嘛
對不對
這種基本上公關要做好
那這樣子就會
就會很快就合可
然後可是從這個
瓦特到幾個瓦
其實為什麼
因為每個這個 GPU
它使用的電量越來越高
從過去40到50kW
然後一直到這個整個機位
現在可能上看750kW這樣子
那需要的電力越高
它就去對於伺服器的電源的TOM
就是整個市場需求
成長率你知道高達多少嗎
我看一下數字我嚇到
因為我過去常來理財大人秀
我們常常講說你看CaGR CAG
這35%值得注意
70%
70%的成長
所以全球資料中心的電量需求量
你看超級高
那裡面會有一個到 2030 年有一個缺口是 268 Gbw
還記得上一頁我們說
明年會有多少嗎
我們回顧一下
明年 38
缺口 268
你就知道喔
這真的是缺口非常的大
那缺口這麼大的情況下
升電
然後電怎麼轉到這個 data center 裡面去轉換進去
然後到 data center 裡面怎麼轉換到這個 grid to chip
就是到 chip 端怎麼用到這個電
我覺得這裡面就產生很多的商機
因為它的缺口這麼大
所以要如火如荼的
一定要
增加這些基礎設施
沒錯
好
像這個大廠 Trendforce 就發布有電力缺口
再來呢 輝達的部分 跟 Google 結盟
他們看 呼朋引伴啊
趕快來做
那個電力的部分 有問題了
因為他們發現
過去像 GPU 在算力的部分
然後這個
我們可能還在散熱的部分也很重視
發現電力也不行了
要趕快來
所以呢 呼朋引伴
像 Google 跟輝達去結這個 AEMA 的聯盟
另外 Amazon 也入股這個
Jana AEC 公司
所以股價一天跳空 30%
我覺得有點激勵這個族群的感覺
過來 Google 它也跟歐洲分擔的公司
簽這個 150 億美元的 PPA
這是 Power Purchase Agreement
就是有一個 22 年的
很長的一個採購合約
因為它在歐洲建 Data Center 一定要電
那這個核電的部分
是它的選擇之一
如果它沒有保障好它的來電的話
它就沒有 Output 沒有 Token 可以用
那可是啊就是跟不上 AI 的速度
美國基礎電力設施其實
我們可以從幾個數據來看出來
剛才說到這個跳空 30%
那這個 Janet AC
那除了它以外
其實我把這幾家
大家可以特別留意一下
觀察一下 最終一下這幾家
像這個 Vertiv 啊
Eton 啊 或是 GE
或是這個廣達
不是台灣的廣達
是美國的廣達
或是 Blue Energy
這幾家公司都有幾個狀況
比如說營收年增
然後創新高
再來是 Q2調整之後創高 裁測上修
再來在手訂單創新高
在手訂單很高 雙雙創高
再來手計破10億美元 由虧轉移
從這些跡象可以看得出來
這些公司雖然都在右下角
大家可以去看右下角
主要是因為過去的 4-Wall PE 還是相對比較高一點
所以做了一個修正
那修正完畢之後呢
看到未來實際上並沒有變
那花若盛開 蝴蝶自來
我覺得未來蝴蝶就會來他們之前股價多多少少也強勢過可是你看這一波META大漲然後AMD創新高Intel也在大漲那他們為什麼需求剛剛前面看了那麼多
還沒有辦法輪到他們咧
主要就是因為
過去的那個我剛才提到的PE有點高
包含我們台灣的台大電
是
過去它的PE可能到了40倍以上
你就覺得不可思議
以前台大電你怎麼算怎麼算
就450塊就是緊繃了
那朋友問我說 450 塊賣掉
結果賣掉就賣飛了
直接掉到 2500 塊
可是到了 2500 塊
你再回頭去看的時候
當你看台牙店的 4-World PE 你會怕到
你會覺得說哎呀
要休息一下休息一下
當你當初在看跌回來的旗紅
你會覺得
不會怕
因為 4-World PE 你看到未來
就獲利就擺在那邊
你不會怕
所以呢
我覺得這個部分
它的速度
就必須要讓時間去發酵
你要等它啦
就像小孩子啊
長大
你要等他
你哭了在那邊很急
有沒有要助長
這個東西就是要時間
那待會我們看他們的
今年的獲利跟明年獲利預估
你會覺得說還不錯
實際上更厲害的是後年的預估
是 因為
Vertif 或者是像B
會連到台灣什麼
麒紅 高麗
他們都很厲害啊
對啊
紅紅台股這波比較厲害
對 上次來講電源
講這個散熱
還有散熱沒事
現在只好來講電源
來救救電源
你看看這一排
重電股
艾倫都沒在講
因為這不符合動能
這不行
這個右側交易者完全不行
你看
可是雖然不行
主要是因為過去他的本益比
因為他過去成長很高
大家用這種折旋估值一折回來
這個像華盛可能一千多塊
但是
折旋是把未來都算進來
可是你發現說他本益比就變相對比較高一點
他修正了很久 整理了很久
但是這些人你看他的訂單
AIDC的訂單從121到200億是不是衝高了
外銷比重也很高也打進STARGAT
另外像市電再手訂單600億能見度
這不是我寫的喔我去找資料的
到29 30耶
可以講到這麼遠嗎
可以喔
明年的我覺得都有點變數
沒關係至少人家是樂觀的
然後過來像中興店
過去也因為是軍工他有一些
其實也算是在高級大陸上
還是在高級大陸上
還可以說
對於看來的
因為我沒有認識
我沒有認識我沒有認識我沒有認識我沒有認識我沒有認識對於一個人我沒有認識我沒有認識我沒有認識人家還是有賺錢的而且它是GIS的龍頭在台灣裡面有很多這種就是我們的伺服器中心裡面的像冷氣、電機超過應該七、八成都是它在做的
在手訂單
也有默默的在耕耘
不是沒做事
雖然說股價很弱
但是人家還是有做事
能見度到2029
那其他像大同東元
也是就是紛紛的開始轉換到
跟像META合作
或是跟資料中心合作
好
那這一組的話
本一筆相對都很合理了
本來之前大家都滑成50倍
現在也默默的回到30幾倍了
對喔 是是是
所以在這裡面我覺得
最近有點整理
大家都不敢講的一檔股票
勇者 勇者來了
那這個 中興電呢
它第二季營收稍微有激增了
16% 年增6%
有回來重點是毛利率
創經濟新高
我覺得這代表產品組合做得還不錯
是
再來呢
今年也跨入 AI Data Center 裡面的一些
統包或是一些工程
中華電信跟四方在台灣
主要是它的客戶這樣子
加動率
加動率有100%以上
它加動率這麼高
對 120%
其實就是有點加班的意思
因為我們以前的加動率
大概就是 90% 80% 就很滿了
如果你要再高一點點
就是可能把辦公室拿來做
沒有啦
就是加班 然後辦公室拿來做
比平常的這種產能
還要再高出一點
所以加動率比較高
再來資本支出小修
小修上修到15到21
代表人家還是有點企圖心
那股價呢
這個要問艾倫了
看起來
感覺起來
怎麼樣
下業
我本來想把拋丟給他了
結果
不是 他不是快表態了
正上所有均線嗎
其實還不錯啊
就差放量一根紅K
沒有量
技術分析大師
對
是是是
觀察啦
我們都是觀察一下嘛對不對
那另外我們也可以看到這個 Post-Pride Unit
它的佔比啊 有些人看到這報告的時候
其實有點怕掉 會覺得說
欸 你看它的佔比喔
就是綠色那部分 PSU 綠色
是
有沒有覺得嚇到
14%到8%
到202627以上就開始8%
可是實際上是因為
GPU的價格越來越高
因為我們很少看到你會挑那個佔比越來越小的來講
這故意挑的
那原因是GPU的價格越來越高
加上它GPU 配套的措施
譬如說一冷散熱 機櫃
這些都是變成說它的 Power Supply Unit 的占比變少可是要再附上這個就是吃藥的時候要配水的意思一樣你要知道它的 Power Supply Unit 的占比變少可是要再附上這個就是吃藥的時候要配水的意思一樣你要知道喔它的 Power Supply Unit 金額持續增加
而且是大幅增加
我們剛才說有一個 69% 很厲害了
我們這邊就看到一個巨怪
這個大物 120%
Kag 120%
也就是說它雖然的占比變少
但數量跟金額是這樣提升的
原因是因為它的含金量很高
從過去的 Harper 0.4%
WAPER 0.42 per watt
就是每一瓦
到了這個 VeroVit
阿伯隆
它是0.93
這乘了幾乎兩倍以上
所以相關的
這個整個 Pulse Part Unit 裡面
沒有那麼小
那麼長
這裡面有很多供應鏈
譬如說 PSU 的廠商
功率元件
磁性元件
電容散熱
因為也要散熱
這個功率也會高
它需要散熱
再來這個固態變壓器
電源 PMIC 控制 IC
都會受惠
因為這裡面的需求
裡面的需求規格技術提升
所以這些人都有機會隨著技術提升
然後他的含金量就增加
不過電源供應器廠商大廠小廠很多
然後供應元件的話等一下也會聊
6月的時候說什麼市場上都買不到供應元件
結果7月的時候跌得稀巴爛
可是電源的部分其實是一直在跌代
一直在升級的
從過去啊像這個過去伺服器的一邊
1.1到3kW
然後到近期的這個5.5到12kW
大部分就 5.5-12kW
然後呢
到了
接著要 400-800V
你們想一下
裡面的這些銅線
這麼粗一根嗎
那個廠商會破廠
因為那個價格很高
所以我們必須要把這個電壓提高
800V是不得不
有些人會擔憂
說這個800V可能沒有
會延後
我想跟大家講
比大家想的樂觀
有些人說要到 2028
我覺得 2027就會開始
有佔比會提升了
然後再來到未來就是 SST 固態變壓
固態變壓器
好 那除了它以外
在櫃子裡面或櫃子外面
也會搭配一些BBU
所以BBU最近
老實說也沒什麼表現
但是這個有人說BBU不是標配
不是百分之百用
我確定不是百分之百
可是它的比重會越來越提升
從過去的10%
一直到50%到60%以上
那過去的機期很低
機期很低
它的價格呢
從 720 塊到未來是 24,000 塊
你看看這成長有多大
那過去 GCD 明年開始出貨
那明年後年大後年成長就變了
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕